touch up all olympics why don't we get
into it
tokyo olympics opening draws 16.7
million u.s
tv viewers 33-year low that's
pretty low by the way to say 33 or low
that's a long time nbc broadcasted tokyo
olympics
opening uh ceremony for only 16.7
million viewers the smallest television
audience for the last 33 years
uh it declined 37 from 2016 when 26.5
million people watched the rio de
janeiro games open and 59
down from 2012 when 40.7 million people
watch the london ceremony it was the
lowest audience for the opening since
1980 at seoul games
which attracted 22.7 million tv viewers
nbc universal which paid 7.65 billion
dollars
to extend its u.s broadcast right for
the olympics through 2032 plans
to air an unprecedented seven hours of
olympic coverage across
multiple television networks and peacock
streaming services
is what they're saying so uh what are
your thoughts about that for being down
what is the reason for it when you watch
some of these matches there's nobody in
audience is it because
of covet is it lack of interest is that
you're saying in japan
yeah why are why is the tv viewership in
us so low
well you know they say when you lose one
sense the other senses
get you know stronger if you lose your
sense of sight your sense of of hearing
gets stronger well when the rich lost
their sense of humor their sense of
self importance got stronger and this is
just non-stop
preaching it's not there's nothing fun
about any of this have you watched any
of this
there's nothing fun there's no more fun
in sports there's no more fun
in television like even even in the nfl
draft did you watch the nfl draft
it was not what this kid did in college
it was well he comes from the poorest
neighborhood in the poorest state and
his mother had 18
jobs a day and it's okay you can root
for this kid
he's not one of these rich kids it's
okay it's it's okay he's going to be a
multi-millionaire in the nfl
they're doing the same thing they're
like i don't care how bad everybody had
it i care
are you awesome at your sport i i came
here to see
excellence i came here to see absolute
the pinnacle
of human achievement and politics have
just infiltrated this
entire thing there are judokas like my
father was an olympic alternate in judo
i watched judo all right i like judo i
was a judoka
and these dudes won't fight the israeli
champion
they won't they're literally pulling out
of the olympics because they refuse
for political reasons to get in the ring
i won't i won't touch that
it was uh the first one was i think i
don't i don't want to get it wrong i
believe it was azerbaijan and algeria
are those the two
i don't want to get it wrong but they
literally pulled out because they they
wouldn't stand on the same mat with an
israeli
and the whole pull up that story the
whole point of the olympics by the way
for people that know the history of the
olympics
it came together as the it was the
original united nations
in greece there were so many warring
city-states that they were like look
instead of us killing
tens of thousands of each other like
every year why don't we just have these
games and we'll wrestle naked and
we'll meet each other have some wine
that'll be cool to be told what you just
did is what needs to be told
what you said is what needs to be told
the wrestling naked party that's the
part that's it
it's it's just a lot of eye contact
coming together part yes what no what
no no not the coming together but what
needs to be told is
when a marriage is in a bad place you
have to remind them why did you guys
date in the first place
what brought you guys together there's a
right before divorce that's a
conversation
america needs to know history of why
olympics
is the olympics so is this one you're
talking about a a second judoka pulls
out of the olympics an apparent move to
avoid
facing israeli sudans mohammed abba
dalar soul skips bout with tohar but
who wins next fight but loses metal
chance later athlete is a no-show
despite
cartoon signing abraham accords with
israel the second number i'm going to go
a little lower
suspended for doing the same but paul
was listed there's no competitor no it's
not going to 73.
cameron olympic officials that didn't
show to facebook in their route despite
weighing in about early international
judo federation didn't immediately
announce the reason van gaal comes in
giving a
okay so you know here's my question yeah
is that his decision or are there people
behind this
good point pulling strings that's a good
question there's no way we can have one
of our
athletes lose to an israeli or even
israeli
so it's not a good look for us so we're
gonna make a political stance here
and we're not gonna fight this guy's
been training his whole life now he's
about to win the gold or like sorry
buddy have a seat what but take that
exactly what you said is right now
extrapolate that out
right you think you think multiple
sports yeah like do you think lebron
james is coming up with like
with minister farrakhan's words on his
own or do you think somebody from the
nation of islam is like you know what
you should say something like this
like these people have infiltrated the
highest levels of our culture
you think simone biles is backing out
because the the you know the gymnastics
aspect of this is the pressure she can't
handle of course it's not
she's the best gymnast possibly of all
time this is second hat to her it's
probably what she loves more than
anything in the world
the pressure of being pulled in
different directions by these incredibly
powerful people
is what she's going like you know what
screw it i'm not here to be your mascot
i'm not here to be the mascot of your
social action
i'm not here to be the mask out of this
side or that side i just want to perform
and these dudes out here again four
years
of competition to get to the highest
level and now you have somebody and
because of political differences you're
not going to compete
but why let me say why is this why is
guys why is viewership down
why is viewership in u.s down that's
look i think a part of it
is you know people just like what you
said about the nba why was the viewer
view of a viewership up they took all
the political stuff away from it they
said listen just come here enjoy sports
right i think that's obviously a factor
here in the olympics and i think also a
part
of it we all feel for the athletes we're
all rooting for the athletes sure
i think lingering maybe this is for me
it's my opinion
i'm not that interested in olympics for
whatever reason
because i think that the committees and
whoever's putting everything together is
just corrupt
when i think of the olympics i think of
corruption i do
how do these countries get it they built
it listen you hear these stories
about china building these ridiculous
stadiums
and then after the olympics they're gone
they don't even use the average person
in america is not watching olympics
because they think the judges are
corrupt
say judges the overall olympic
committees
the selection the way that they pick the
cities
i'm just saying i just think it's not
fun anymore
they don't know how to create fun
products i don't know i have my okay you
don't think the olympics was corrupted
at all
the audience by the way i won't actually
hear you guys why do you kai why do you
think i want to know if you guys do you
guys have any opinions on this or not at
all
it has to be if you haven't if it's
different than what they said say it if
not
i have one i think um a big one is
obviously what you guys have mentioned
uh in terms of that second one is the
fact that the whole last year is it
happening
is it not oh [ __ ] it happens tomorrow
wait it actually started okay so i think
that is a big open field scheduling yes
okay schedule not enough good marketing
yes just confusion of like because i saw
articles still
the week of it could still be cancelled
like all right is it going on is it not
the other part second part which also i
think is a big part uh
they're cur japan is currently 13 hours
ahead so the schedule they're competing
in the middle of the night so yeah but
china was the same yeah
that's not as big but i think the
biggest one is the fact that they were
uh like is it happening is it being
canceled okay what do you guys think
anything different or no
david uh i just yeah i never really had
much interest in the olympics i think
it's a historic event then it's a
no-brainer-free like it's a
non-issue for you like who cares okay
even the soccer moment i will say as it
gets down to more of the finals
viewership is going to go theater does
bother me the kabuki theater bothers me
where it's like okay everybody's wearing
a mask
but then the mask is down over here and
then now they got to go compete face to
face with each other it's like
it's just too much like safety theater
for me i
i don't feel like i'm watching a
competition i feel like i'm watching
propaganda i'm trying to see if that's
how
the average viewer feels the way
you do so there is how i feel there's
how you feel then there's
the average american that's like just
not watching it why so you're saying
because of the committee you're saying
because of
the you know it's not fun anymore it's
just too politicized
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
you